le parti communiste mobilisent contre
jean marie le pen plusieurs
manifestations en france contre le
leader du front national qui est invitée
de l'heure de vérité ce soir sur antenne
résidentiel ouverture de la bataille des
bilans économiques les barriste décerne
à zéro pointé à celui des années
mitterrand
la france dit il joue maintenant en
seconde division cinq industriels
français inculte et pour livraison vers
l'urss de matériel illicite précisément
l'otan étudient à versailles le
renforcement de la protection des
technologies de pointe enlèvement à
beyrouth d'un ingénieur ouest allemands
alors que se déroule à düsseldorf le
procès de abbas hamadé ralph faille et
le troisième allemand et le 20e
étrangers détenus ou disparus
au liban une journée supplémentaire de
détention pour marcel fontaine jean paul
kauffmann marcel carton les otages
français au liban n'ont toujours pas été
libérés sidéens une nouvelle
terminologie à la une de l'actualité un
mot créé de toutes pièces pour désigner
les victimes du sida aujourd'hui c'est
cette lettre nous troublent d'autant
plus qu'elles concernent des enfants
à new york je le disais à l'instant un
bébé sur 61 est atteint du sida un
chiffre effrayant qui met l'accent sur
l'autre réalité de la maladie
une réalité que l'on a parfois des
scrupules à montrer enquête à new york
de paul nahon et francis friedland
il aura fallu déployer des trésors
d'imagination et de patience pour
pouvoir ouvrir cette maison dans le new
jersey ici les enfants sont beaux et
apparemment en bonne santé
apparemment seulement car leur petite
ville tient plus qu'à un fil un rhume
une angine une coupure atteints du sida
ils n'ont plus de défenses immunitaires
et dans quelques mois ou quelques années
mélissa ionique katia vont mourir ils
ont été contaminés par leur mère le
docteur zealand et sa femme ont décidé
de créer ce centre il y a un an mais il
aura fallu d'abord convaincre les
autorités
certains ont été réticentes au ce sont à
peu près d'une extrême générosité
elle juste à côté il y à un marchand de
glaces nous avions très peur qu'ils
s'opposent à l'ouverture de cette maison
nous avons parlé avec lui il a trouvé
l'idée très généreuse et depuis l'envoi
des glaces gratuitement pour tous les
enfants
nous essayons de nous concentrer sur la
qualité de vie de ses enfants et non pas
sur la quantité ou l'espérance de vie
ici vous savez chaque petite chose
devient très importante
seule précaution apparente les gants que
porte le personnel pour changer soigner
les enfants tout est fait pour ne pas
trop les séparés de leur mère mais dans
la plupart des cas la mère se trouve à
l'hôpital
incapable de s'en occuper aujourd'hui à
new york
un enfant sur 61 et chaque mois avec le
sida et aux états unis en 1990 trois
mille bébés naîtront avec la maladie
le problème du sida chez les homosexuels
est en train de se ralentir étant donné
grâce à une réaction des groupes
homosexuels
malheureusement en ce moment l'infection
se développe d'une manière
extraordinaire chez les toxicomanes
environ à peu près 7 % des patients
atteints du sida sont des des femmes en
âge de porter des enfants est à peu près
lors d'une grossesse il ya une
probabilité de 35 à 50 % pour ces femmes
de donner naissance à un enfant affectés
par le sida
ces porteurs du sida hommes femmes
enfants on les trouve désormais en
majorité dans les ghettos des grandes
villes la maladie frappe en priorité les
noirs et les hispaniques les couches les
plus défavorisées la nation les plus
touchés aussi par les problèmes de
drogue en 1990 en amérique trois cent
mille personnes seront atteintes par le
sida ou prévoient un mort toutes les dix
minutes
si d'ici là aucun vaccin n'est trouvé
oui vous l'avez compris les chiffres new
yorkais les chiffres américains sont
sont impressionnants est ce qu'il existe
des données françaises aussi alarmiste
jean daniel flaysakier non parce que la
situation n'est pas la même pour je
dirais que c'est eux et nous c'est nous
les chiffres ne sont pas tout à fait les
mêmes parce que new york représente
peut-être dans le monde occidental ce
qui est de pire en matière de risques
d'infection a été notamment la
toxicomanie comme le disait paul nahon
mais il n'empêche qu'en france
aujourd'hui on estime le haut de la
fourchette que 0,7 pour cent des femmes
en âge d'avoir un enfant sont porteuses
du virus 0 7% de femmes enceintes
d'après les études quand on sait qu'une
femme à un risque sur 10 environ de
transmettre le virus à son enfant cela
fait quand même quatre enfants pour
mille en france qui veut dire peut-être
n'ont-ils sus très simple que chaque
jour en france naissent entre cinq et
dix enfants contaminés par le virus des
enfants pour lesquels le pronostic reste
malheureusement pressons le dépistage
systématique dont on parle beaucoup
c'est une solution j'en alliance
nationaux pas la solution et tous les
spécialistes s'accordent à dire qu'il
est inutile pourquoi parce qu'elle a
encore toutes les études faites à grande
échelle ont montré que les femmes à
risque
on les connaît bien ce sont d'abord les
toxicomanes ou celles dans le conjoint
est un toxicomane les drogués paye le
plus lourd tribut actuellement chez les
jeunes femmes
ensuite il ya celle dont qui ont eu des
partenaires multiples et dont le
conjoint ou elles mêmes sont originaires
d'afrique centrale des zones à haut
risque
et puis celles qui ont été transfusés à
plusieurs reprises avant août 85 avant
qu'on mette en route
le dépistage dépit le dépistage sanguin
dans les bandes 800 dépister
systématiquement toutes les femmes se
seraient d'abord médicaments inutiles ça
sans suites économiquement ruiné faire
dix mille 15 mille tests pour rien alors
qu'on trouverait peut-être un cas
positif pisser majorer le risque de
trouver des tests faussement positifs
d'obliger des femmes qui sont un thème
de contamination à interrompre leur
grossesse alors qu'elles n'ont rien avec
l'enfant qu'elle porte n'ont rien mais
je voudrais vous dire une chose en
conclusion henry sait qu'en france on a
peut-être des médecins les biologistes
parmi les plus réputés au monde et pas
les plus qualifiés pour travailler sur
le sida eux savent ce qu'ils disent eux
savent ce qu'ils doivent nous dire est
ce que l'on doit faire à partir de leurs
conseils eux qui sont
gage et en particulier de toute
préoccupation électorale merci jean
marie le pen alors de vérité c'est
incontestablement l'événement politique
de la soirée ce soir sur antenne 2 dans
une demi heure à peu près le leader du
front national répondra aux questions
d'alain duhamel jean françois kahn et
albert du roy le passage de jean marie
le pen à l'heure de vérité suscite
quelques réactions c'est le moins que
l'on puisse dire le mrap mouvement
contre le racisme et pour l'amitié entre
les peuples à manifester longuement hier
soir dès hier à marseille dans les
bouches du rhône le pc était également
descendus dans la rue avec les
représentants d'une vingtaine
d'associations et puis nouvelles
manifestations ce soir à paris de la
république à la bastille en première
ligne le pc les jeunesses communistes la
cgt l'unef et l'amicale des algériens en
france
bref le parti communiste a fait de ce
mercredi 27 janvier 88 une véritable
journée anti le pen
andré lajoinie l'a rappelé tout à
l'heure c'était à marseille
le plus surprenant dans ce meeting du
parti communiste c'est qu'il est attiré
aussi peu de monde dès 2000 jeunes
attendus tout juste 500 s'étaient
déplacés
d'autant plus surprenant que le thème
était ce soir le racisme or à marseille
c'est justement l'un des problèmes qui
préoccupent le plus les habitants de la
cité phocéenne
d'ailleurs andré lajoinie vient à
l'instant même de lancer une nouvelle
fois un appel sans équivoque contre la
candidature le pen
le pen il ne faut pas jouer avec lui il
ne faut pas s'en servir comme d'un
repoussoir oudon servat loire il faut le
combattre
parce que le pen c'est le racisme et le
racing ce n'est pas une opinion c'est un
délit
je dirais même que c'est un crime
puisqu'il ya eu aujourd'hui des morts
victimes du racisme dans ce pays
le monsieur lawani vous ne pensez pas
qu'en parlant souvent de lui vous lui
faites indirectement la publicité non je
crois qu'il faut le démasquer et le
battre de faire reculer de beaucoup
d'autres forces politiques se servent de
le pen
nous ne jouons pas avec lui nous le
combattons nous le démasquons car c'est
l'intérêt de notre peuple
c'est l'intérêt la démocratie convaincu
de l'attitude à avoir face au candidat
du front national
andré lajoinie développera dans quelques
minutes une fois de plus cette position
têtu après marseille sous un autre
chapiteau celui d'arles économie et
politique l'état major de raymond barre
dresse un bilan plutôt sévère vous allez
l'entendre des années mitterrand bruno
durieux le conseiller économique de
raymond barre donne un zéro pointé au
bilan socialiste pour lui c'est en se
résume en un seul mot recul 81 88 le
premier bilan des sept années mitterrand
établi par les maristes et économique
on pouvait s'y attendre l'analyse et
scrupuleuse la dissection méticuleuse
mais la digestion est plutôt difficile à
prix très moyen emploi effondrement
commerce extérieur catastrophe
investissements décrochage bref pour les
maristes la france les joues plus en
première division mais en seconde
division les années mitterrand nous ont
coûté 1000 francs par mois et par
famille du fait qu'on a perdu du
dynamisme dans la croissance et les
revenus elles nous ont coûté 600 mille
emplois l'ensemble de nos partenaires
européens a retrouvé son plus haut
niveau d'emplois de 1980
nous sommes encore en dessous à hauteur
de 600 mille emplois de ce niveau avant
80 on était plus dynamique on était plus
créateurs d'emplois que les autres pays
et à troisième conclusion majeure c'est
que les années mitterrand
douze ont fait perdre un client étranger
sur cinq
en réalité ce bilan est complètement
indécent bar s'énerve parce qu'il se
rend compte que chirac est en train de
lui passer devant
il est indécent prenons l'exemple de la
croissance les résultats qu'il met en
avant sont mauvais mais ils sont mauvais
parce qu'on mélange les deux périodes
celle des socialistes et celle de chirac
sur la période socialiste la croissance
française est meilleur que la croissance
européenne
mais sur les années 87 88 elle est moins
bonne quand on réunit le tout c'est
mauvais en réalité en croyant attaqué
mitterrand barre dans cette affaire
ataka directement chirac
je crois qu'il fait du billard à deux
bandes qui a fait quoi qui attaque qui
qui a dit quoi sur qui premier bilan
première empoignade
c'est bien le coup d'envoi du jeu du
petit cochonnet qui se joue à trois avec
bar chirac et mitterrand
voilà vous l'avez compris polémique sur
les chiffres c'est pas vraiment nouveau
philippe sassier bon a priori ce sont
les analystes qui divergent car les
chiffres bas ils sont officiels sont les
chiffres de l' ocde sont plusieurs des
chiffres officiels en tout cas précis un
bilan réquisitoire du septennat de
françois mitterrand bruno durieux a
puisé ces chiffres chez les bons auteurs
l' ocde l'insee ou bien le ministère des
finances il a systématiquement comparer
les performances françaises aux
performances étrangères et notamment
européennes et alors que dans le camp
socialiste on s'apprête à défendre
l'idée que le libéralisme et bien c'est
dans l'impasse bruno durieux lui affirme
que le septennat de françois mitterrand
marque un recul dans tous les domaines
économiques et sociaux un bilan qui va
certainement déclenché une belle
bataille de chiffres en effet en jouant
sur les années de référence on peut avec
mêmes chiffres aboutir à des conclusions
différentes bruno durieux s'ingénie à
démolir certains résultats présentés par
les socialistes comme des succès les
prix le financement de la sécurité
sociale notamment et il insiste sur le
retard français investissement
croissance et emploi sa conclusion en 81
la france jouer en première division
elle se trouve aujourd'hui en deuxième
la difficulté consistait à ne pas jeter
le bébé avec l'eau du bain c'est à dire
les deux ans de jacques chirac avec le
septennat de françois mitterrand le
baril si mme durrieu a trouvé une
réponse depuis 86 ça va mieux dans
l'entourage de jacques chirac on reste
très serein
les flèches de cet expert polytechnicien
vise l'elysée et non pas matignon
l'autre image politique de la journée
sensiblement différente valéry giscard
d'estaing à verdun
sur le doubs en campagne c'est dans
cette petite commune de saône-et-loire
que l'ancien président avait prononcé
son fameux discours du bon choix il y a
dix ans dix ans plus tard valéry giscard
d'estaing ne s'engagera pas directement
dans la bataille il s'en est expliqué à
plusieurs reprises mais avec l'udf il
soutiendra le député de lyon
verdun sur le doubs accueille ce soir et
non sans émotion un hôte de marque
valéry giscard d'estaing il est revenu
comme il y a dix ans fidèle au souvenir
c'est le maire de verdun
les gardiens maurice duvernois qui
l'accueille
vge est visiblement ému il n'a pas
oublié souvenez-vous janvier 78 le pays
est à la veille d'une élection
législative importante la gauche gagne
du terrain
vge demande aux français qui ont voté
pour lui de ne pas se déjuger en lui
donnant une majorité pour gouverner
c'est le bon choix et les français
écouteront aujourd'hui les habitants de
verdun et leur mère donc maurice
duvernois n'ont pas oublié c'est
vraiment de l'amour avenue valéry
giscard d'estaing la stèle du bon choix
la rue du 27 janvier tout est fait pour
rappeler à l'illustré invité de ce jour
qu'il avait fait voici dix ans la
conquête de ce petit village de saône et
loire un vge visiblement nostalgique qui
ne manquera pas de se souvenir qu'il
avait annoncée ce jour là que la
constitution n'interdit n'est pas de
gouverner avec la gauche
cela ne s'appelait pas encore la
cohabitation le sondage du jour si l'on
en croit le dernier bébé à paris match
la popularité de jacques chirac et
grimpe de 9 points et celle de françois
mitterrand de deux points bilan 52% des
français ont une bonne opinion du
premier ministre françois mitterrand
recueillant pour sa part 61% d'opinions
favorables en revanche 59% des personnes
interrogées se disent mécontentes de la
façon dont la france est gouvernée
sans commentaire les femmes en l'an 2000
c'est le thème des assises nationales
qui se déroulait aujourd'hui à paris à
l'initiative de la délégation à la
condition féminine
tout au long de la journée on a évoqué
l'accession croissante des femmes à des
postes de responsabilité ce soir jacques
chirac a clos les travaux et les débats
en proposant notamment l'instauration
d'un chèque temps qui
permettrait aux femmes de prendre des
périodes de repos pour se consacrer à la
formation professionnelle
sur le terrain l'équipe d'antenne 2
essayer de voir comment la loi de 1983
loi sur l'égalité des femmes étaient
appliquées 18 entreprises en france
l'appliquent
parmi elles moulinex il faut dire que 67
% de l'effectif est constituée de femmes
et que 80% d'entre elles travaillent à
la chaîne en quête de françois jeu ces
gestes saccadés répétitives plus de 4000
femmes les exécute chaque jour chez
moulinex avec le premier plan d'égalité
professionnelle lancé en 1984 une
centaine d'entre elles ont échappé au
travail à la chaîne
aujourd'hui après deux ans de formation
elle travaille au contrôle de la
production au réglage des machines et
même dans les bureaux d'études
mais à 33 ou 34 ans retournée à l'école
n'a pas été facile bon bah j'avais un
peu peur de ne pas réussir cette
formation parce que fall et retourne à
l'école ça faisait 15 ans que je n'étais
pas retourné
donc j'avais peur d'avoir des
difficultés sur certains niveaux quoi
mais ces femmes sont allés jusqu'au bout
de leurs efforts à 98% elles ont réussi
leur cap2 mécanique d'entretien
aujourd'hui dans leur nouvelle tâche
elles sont mieux payés et surtout elle
trouve dans leur travail
un véritable intérêt
du travail quand même totalement
différent de mettre une plaque et trois
vices avons cherché pas vraiment à quoi
ça servait que maintenant bon -
cherchent à s'enrichir de plus en plus
quand on évolue
cette évolution n'est pas seulement
professionnelle ces femmes mères de
famille suivent désormais plus
facilement la scolarité de leurs enfants
cela me permet de pouvoir les aider dans
leurs études parce que ça m'a fait une
révision de toutes les matières là les
parents furent de ficalba de la
thématique offrant faut qu'on fasse la
formation de 600 femmes a coûté 10
millions de francs à moulinet l'état y
étaler sa poche en finançant 30% de
l'opération enfin la requalification de
ces ouvrières permet à l'entreprise
d'être plus compétitif un tiers du
personnel féminin de production devra
passer l'information d'ici fin 88
ça doit nous permettre de préparer les
gens aux changements aux évolutions
d'entreprise notamment la polyvalence un
extension des tâches et à la mobilité
dans toute la france seuls 18
entreprises se sont lancées dans ses
plans d'égalité professionnelle
une avancée qui reste somme toute bien
modeste 5 français inculpé aujourd'hui
pour intelligence avec des agents d'une
puissance étrangère l'information était
confirmée cet après midi au moment même
où s'ouvrait à versailles la réunion du
coct comme qui est le comité de
coordination pour le contrôle des
exportations
en deux mots il s'agit de protéger nos
technologies de pointe qui sont très
convoités semble-t-il par l'urss et les
pays de l'est
hervé brusini on ne parle pas on
n'approche pas ici top secret réunion du
coct comme seize pays en conclave ce
l'alliance atlantique plus le japon un
objectif commun renforcer les contrôles
sur la vente des produits haut de gamme
ce qui pourrait être utilisé à des fins
militaires
un même adversaire les pays de l'est
mais la grande famille qu comme koné
paraît-il quelques tourments selon les
etats-unis la france serait quelque peu
laxiste dans sa surveillance
alors comme pour démontrer qu'il en est
rien une soudaine révélation le
démantèlement par la dst d'un réseau de
trafiquants 1985 près de marseille
julien di nardo créé sa société la
universal testing equipment un
stratagème pour répondre aux exigences
d'un officier du kgb en poste en france
depuis 78 un officier devenu l'agent
traitant de di nardo et les convoitises
de moscou porte sur ce que fabrique
cette entreprise d'origine allemande la
redondance farce
l'un de ses employés est mis dans le
coup son rôle aurait été de fournir les
fiches techniques les détails sur les
derniers création de redonner schwartz
les documents étaient ensuite
transportés à moscou par di nardo et là
les soviétiques n'avaient plus qu'à
faire leur choix sur catalogue
équipements de mesure ou systèmes de
télécommunication de niveau stratégique
à la radio une farce on ne désire pas
faire de commentaire dernier élément de
la filière une société de fret l'ag
raviat dont un bureau existe ici à
marseille trois de ses employées
auraient effectué les formalités
douanières avant d'acheminer le matériel
vers l'urss et cinq français impliqués
dans cette affaire ont tous avoué
il risque entre 10 et 20 ans de
réclusion la chirac l'annoncé hier soir
330 avions rafale équiperont l'armée
française une commande qui pèse très
lourd 175 milliards de francs et qui
donne du travail jusqu'à la fin du
siècle à certains industriels français
reste que pour convaincre les sceptiques
il y en a encore semble-t-il beaucoup le
rafale doit aussi conquérir le marché
mondial autant dire que le plus dur
reste à faire
laurent boussier satisfaction et
soulagement chez les industriels
interrogations et vigilance dans l'armée
de l'air
légère déception pour la marine les
décisions prises hier en conseil
interministériel auront eu au moins
l'avantagé de lever les ambiguïtés qui
depuis sept mois
entouraient le lancement du programme
rafale deux prototypes construits dès
1990 330 exemplaires à produire à partir
de 1996 cet énorme bol d'oxygène
financier va permettre à dassault mais
aussi à la snecma ja thompson d'avoir du
travail jusqu'à la fin du siècle
cette victoire des industriels ne doit
pas faire oublier les menaces qui pèsent
sur l'avion 175 milliards c'est cher
très cher surtout si le rafale reste un
avion exclusivement français
rendus sur le seul marché intérieur
c'est le souci d' andré giraud ministre
de la défense pour qui il n'y a pas
d'autre solution que des coopérations
industrielles avec les pays les plus
développés
des discussions ont lieu actuellement
avec la belgique l'espagne l'angleterre
et même les états unis des discussions
mais pour l'instant pas de
concrétisation
ce sera pourtant une question de survie
dans l'armée de l'air on insiste sur le
cahier des charges de l'avion définitif
qui devra être plus léger et surtout
plus discret que le prototype
actuellement en essais enfin dans la
marine où l'on sait qu'un avion
navalisée n'a pas toujours les
performances d'un avion spécifiquement
étudiée pour l'aéronavale
on déplore l'arrivée tardive du rafale
dans les unités 1996 ce sera trois ans
après la mise au placard des cruise a
l'air voilà c'est tout ce que l'on peut
dire ce soir les autres télégramme
d'actualité commenté par isabelle staes
hosni moubarak à washington le président
égyptien vient demander le soutien des
états unis pour relancer le processus de
paix au proche orient
hosni moubarak sera reçu demain par
ronald reagan arrivera dimanche à femmes
felipe gonzalez demande au congrès
américain de faire un geste pour la paix
en amérique centrale
l'espagne est prête à vérifier
l'application des accords de paix a
déclaré le président espagnol au cours
d'un dîner avec daniel ortega le
président du nicaragua qui poursuit sa
tournée en europe sera demain à rome
super show à l'américaine pour les deux
derniers nés de la famille boeing voici
le 747-400 le plus grand avion civil du
monde avec pilotage à deux autres
versions améliorées d'un ancien modèle
de 737 400 un sérieux concurrent pour
l'airbus a320 c'est vos appareils
entreront en service à l'automne dans le
conflit inter la cour d'appel de paris
donne raison pilotes
elle est il que la justice n'est pas
compétente pour apprécier la légitimité
des revendications en juillet 96 le
tribunal de créteil avait jugé unis si
la grèce des pilotes et mécaniciens à
paris le procès de christian david alias
le beau serge a été renvoyée au mercredi
22 mars prochain le renvoi intervient
après quatre heures de suspension
d'audience à la suite du départ des
trois avocats de la défense je vous
rappelle que christian david est accusé
du meurtre d'un commissaire de police
l' affaire remonte à février 66 il ya 22
ans
un bateau pour gaza c'est le slogan
d'une opération lancée hier par ibrahim
sousse le représentant de l'olp et à
paris le but de l'opération est de
réunir 15 millions de francs afin
d'acheter des vivres et surtout des
médicaments pour aider les palestiniens
qui vivent dans les territoires occupés
de cisjordanie et de gaza
ibrahim sousse a reçu le soutien de
monseigneur gaillot l'évêque d'evreux le
parrainage de l'homme d'église n'est pas
réellement surprenant monseigneur
gaillot est déjà intervenue à plusieurs
reprises au plus haut niveau notamment
dans la sphère albertini portrait d'un
évêque
pas tout à fait ordinaire par michel
mompontet visage imposé dans l'actualité
en quelques mois jacques gaillot 52 ans
évêque d'evreux homme de prière mais
aussi
homme de médias ces prises de positions
répétées sur des sujets multiples et
variées en ont fait un évêque presque
célèbre et qui se dit engagé de la
sphère albertini aux objecteurs de
conscience en passant par le désarmement
monseigneur gaillot à exprimer ce qu'ils
pensent tour est très souvent devant des
caméras
est ce que vous vous êtes déjà regardé à
la télé ça m'est arrivé
oui vous trouvez comment
je trouve que
j'ai une voix un petit peu un petit peu
molas mois molas peut-être mais une voix
qui dérange on reproche souvent à cet
évêque peu ordinaire de se mêler de tout
et sans cesse considère que le sacerdoce
doit être engagée et que
l' annonce de l'évangile ne peut se
faire que seuls sur la route des droits
de l'homme le seul combat qui vaille
c'est le combat de l'homme
monseigneur gaillot contre le racisme
il attaque jean marie le pen sur ses
propos ce dernier d'ailleurs lui
reprochera vivement mais il se rendra
aussi en afrique du sud visiter pire
andré albertini est aujourd'hui en
position pour les palestiniens
avec un bateau pour gaza pour gaza voilà
un geste de solidarité envers les
palestiniens des territoires occupés et
je crois qu'un bateau ça permet un des
tas de gens de non seulement d'être
sensibilisés mais d'avoir par de faire
une petite action
cet évêque branché a parfaitement
compris comment utiliser les médias pour
les causes qu'il juge capital
pour lui la télévision c'est mieux
qu'une homélie très facile au rugby on
connaît la composition de l'équipe de
france qui affrontera les cosses dans le
traditionnel tournoi des six nations
c'est le deuxième match de l'année 88 en
principe vous le savez on ne change pas
une équipe qui gagne
les sélectionneurs ont donc considéré la
victoire courte face à l'angleterre
comme une défaite jugez plutôt
quatre changements et non des moindres
jambes amer au moins deux grandes
surprises dans la composition de cette
équipe de france
la première vient de la première ligne
et de la sélection du lourd dé louis
armary à la place de pascal ondarts le
titulaire depuis deux saisons louis
armary 20 ans avait disputé son premier
match international contre la roumanie
en coupe du monde
moins surprenant et le retour de laure
yeux patrick cherrière assurer l'intérim
sur blessure d'alain à leurs yeux
rétablit lorieux récupère donc
logiquement son poste
le choix de jean baptiste lescarboura à
l'ouverture confirme le retour en forme
du dacquois sorti groggy en test match
contre la nouvelle zélande en 86 il
récupère un poste où franck mesnel à
l'époque l'avait remplacé en fin
deuxième grosse surprise le remplacement
d'eric bonneval par patrice lagisquet
bonneval n'a pas retrouvé son meilleur
niveau il n'est même plus remplaçant
dans cette équipe
lagisquet marque et c'est sûr et c'est
il revient donc en équipe de france
voilà les quatre jokers pour
affronter l'ecosse le 6 février prochain
erreur interdite
la météo température clémente pour la
saison on n'est encore qu'en hiver et
inondations en série malheureusement le
rend effectivement nos fleuves sont
d'une humeur débordante en ce moment les
fleuves et les rivières d'ailleurs il
déborde à périgueux voulu du côté de
chartres saumur poitiers limoges sedan
paris bref pratiquement sur une grande
moitié ouest de la france nous sommes
sur des codes d'alert largement dépassé
alors demain quel temps on nous aurons
pratiquement le même temps
qu'aujourd'hui avec tout de même la
perturbation qui était aujourd'hui ce
sur la partie ouest de la france de
légèrement se décaler sur la façade est
ce qui explique donc et quelques
éclaircies que je vous propose
avec la météo nationale sur la carte du
temps pour demain et la couleur du ciel
nous allons juger ces écarts si donc sur
la façade atlantique avec quand même une
poussée nuageuse a peu marqué et même
des pluies assez forte dans l'après midi
sur le littoral méditerranéen
partout ailleurs des nuages sont grandes
intempéries les températures je vous
laisse observer les villes qui vous
concerne voyait une immense douceur
l'excessive douceur même avec 5 à 12
degrés pendant la nuit 12 degrés à
biarritz cette nuit et alors qu'il fera
par exemple ici dans l'aisne à holnon
qu'ils auront 10 degrés demain ou le nom
près de saint-quentin il fera ici aussi
à veules les roses 10° veulent l'hérault
c'est là où se situe le plus petit
fleuve de france qu'il est tout petit
comme ça il mesure 1 km ça existe un
kilomètre mais il ne déborde pas voilà
demain nous célébrerons les thomas
d'aquin le soleil retira six rayons à
17h39 prochain rendez-vous avec
l'actualité 20h30 tout de suite après le
journal avec l'heure de vérité de
françois henri de virieu jean marie le
pen répondra aux questions de trois
confrères albert du roy alain duhamel et
jean françois kahn comme d'habitude j'ai
envie de seine sera fidèle au poste et
svp vous pouvez posez vous aussi vos
questions à 20h30 à 23h30 pardon dernier
journal présenté par aubry et de l'air
demain dès 6h45 n'oubliez pas télé matin
à 7h45 c'est pierre bérégovoy l'ancien
ministre de l'économie et des finances
qui sera l invité des 4 vérités de
gérard morin bonne soirée sur antenne 2
je vous retrouve demain
bonsoir
e